This hyporbola is centered at 1,2 and has an a value of 4 and a b value of 3.
Good work if you got all three. We'll start by graphing the ellipse. The
ellipse will be centered at 1,2. So we go 1 unit right and 2 units up. Next we
move 4 units left and right in the x direction from the value of a, then we
move 3 units up and down and the y direction for the value of b. Now we're
ready to start constructing our hyperbola. We draw a dashed rectangle around
our ellipse and then we connect the diagonals. We'll cut open our ellipse and
then we'll flip the two halves outward, and this will give us our hyperbola. We
want to make sure that the ends of the hyperbola are stretching out to the
diagonals. This curve will always approach this dash diagonal and this dash
diagonal. It's one of the special properties for hyperbolas and you should look
into it more if you're interested.